it's the biggest fire of occupied
dwellings that massive fire that
destroyed an area of downtown now being
compared to a wildfire sally jaramillo
is near charleston fremont where today
crews were going through the rubble once
again sally
yes kirsten as you can imagine a very
scary situation for residents as they
were trying to protect their family
members and of course their homes now
fire crews still out here trying to
determine what caused the blaze
that was 50 units
from around the valley with 150 fire
personnel on scene tim cemanski with las
vegas fire and rescue tells me he can
only think of two to three times in the
valley where they had an alarm this big
these people are coming out there's
glowing fire
it's dark it's real smoky there's people
screaming it was really scary for them
and lives were saved when fire crews
noticed something smoldering in that
area one of our units station 4 unit was
returning the quarters around 16th and
charleston he was at maryland in
charleston he saw a column of smoke says
i'm going to run down here and
investigate it he came down here and as
soon as he was passing by here on
charleston they could see the building
fully involved fire and rescue
investigators as well as the clark
county fire department agents from
alcohol tobacco firearms and explosives
and even an arson dog are looking for
clues to what started the blaze the dog
did not hit on anything there's nothing
that is at this point that is looking
suspicious semanskiasla tells me there
is a lot of homeless in the area and
fireworks fire is serious business and i
think people are waking up to that all
over the united states now
now back out live investigators are
still trying to determine what caused
this they tell me that they're going to
be coming out here still trying to
figure out and put this puzzle together
look at records as well as to these
buildings as what could have happened
here for now reporting live in downtown
las vegas sally jaramillo live local now
sally